[MUSIC]
On behalf of the Stanford Graduate School
of Business,
I'd like to welcome you
to View From The Top.
We are so excited to have you here.
>> Thank you for having me.
>> We have so much to learn from you here
at the GSB about your business Savy and
your tenacity in building
a truly fantastic company.
So I'd like to start today
with the origin of honest.
So much of the company is built upon your
personal experience as a child with health
challenges, and as a mom who struggled to
find products that were affordable and
eco friendly for your own children.
So can you tell us about how these
pain coins led you to developing
a business solution?
>> Yeah, gladly.
I think it really was for me,
Filling a need and
finding a real opportunity to show up,
not just for myself, but
for many people in a way.
I think I was seeing that
companies that make products
that really interact with
you every single day, and
could have an effect on your health and
wellbeing over time.
They just weren't really
considering I think,
holistically your health and
wellness as the top priority.
And for me, I just felt like our
health and wellness, like when you go
through your life and you are thinking
of quality of life and thriving.
And when your health is compromised,
and your health and
wellness is compromised in any way,
shape or
form [COUGH] it's really difficult to
then live a life where you can thrive and
be happy [COUGH] and
live life to the fullest.
So when I was a child,
and I was very sick and
I was constantly reminded
that I wasn't like others.
And I was isolated,
I had severe asthma and allergies.
And every time I had
an allergy to something,
it actually triggered my asthma, and
I was put in the hospital on steroids.
I was in the hospital, I would say
at least three or four times a year,
for a week to two weeks
doing steroid treatments and
breathing treatments and
dealing with pneumonia and bronchitis.
And every cold turned into pneumonia,
so it was just like a whole situation.
[COUGH] But I wanted to play baseball and
soccer and be a normal kid.
And so I would go on the soccer
field with a breathing machine.
And I would have that next to me.
I also had kidney issues and cysts and
many different other
surgeries on top of that,
and all of this before I was 11.
So I just dealt with
a lot of health issues.
And when I was pregnant
with my first daughter,
about 13 years ago,
I had an allergic reaction and
I had pretty much stayed away from
the things that were causing reactions.
And I started to really create
sort of this subconsciously,
the safe environment where
I wasn't exposed to a lot
of the things that would
trigger my allergies or asthma.
And then when I was pregnant with Honor,
I had an allergic reaction
to a detergent that was marketed to
parents to use on their baby's clothing.
And my mom said she used it on me and
I didn't know very many moms.
And when I had this allergic reaction,
I got like a flood of
the memories of me as a kid, and
having all of these health issues.
And I was like, my god,
what if my baby is like me?
What if she has these sort of issues, and
it really kind of shaped who I am and
I think it builds character to
go through difficulties but
it could be avoided, let's avoid them.
I also was dealing with, sorry there's
a plane, they like planes over here.
[LAUGH]
My
mother got cancer when she was,
I believe she was 23,
22 or 23, and
had to have a full hysterectomy.
And meaning she couldn't
have children any more.
And her cancer was environmentally caused
because it was nothing genetically that
was linked to that.
So when I sort of looked, I like took
sort of a reflection on my childhood,
my mom's health and wellness.
Now I'm bringing this little
person into the world and
thinking about quality of
life in a different way.
I was told I wasn't allowed to eat deli
meats, and I couldn't use my retinol on
my face because it could possibly affect
the baby and her health and wellness.
So I started looking at ingredients and
thinking about my health differently and
hers obviously.
And I learned about lots of untested, and
potentially harmful chemicals that we
use and are exposed to on the daily.
And a lot of it is in beauty products,
hair, skin products,
makeup products, fragrances,
home detergents.
And so then I was like, my goodness every
every single day we're being exposed
to all of these potentially harmful
chemicals, and we don't even know it, and
we don't even know how
it's affecting our health.
So then I was looking at,
I looked at data and
was trying to understand the research
around the rise of illness.
And there was a pretty parallel
path in the industrialization
of these chemicals and then being put into
consumer products and beauty products.
And that rise really
paralleled the rise of many
illnesses that people
are dealing with from.
Because they're hormone disruptors,
and they're endocrine disruptors.
[COUGH] And they're linked to
things like various cancers,
learning disabilities, and also
the way that it affects your hormones.
It's basically giving your body steroids.
And it really screws up your hormones,
men and women,
the exposure to a lot of these chemicals.
So, I was like how do we
not know about this, and
how is this even allowed in this country,
shouldn't there be a governing sort
of practice or rules or standards?
And in the UK they actually make companies
test chemicals for safetybBefore they
are even allowed to be brought into the
market place in personal care and beauty.
And in this country, the way that the
system is set up is it has to be proven to
kill enough people before they'll
even look into it being dangerous.
So I was like, what?
So basically we're just being tested on?
And I was like that is so messed up.
And then people who live in
a sort of different circumstances
where they can't necessarily
control their environment and
their shopping Habits because
they're just trying to survive and
they're living paycheck to
paycheck like I grew up.
And a lot of black and brown families
as well are disproportionately
affected by the exposure to
a lot of these chemicals.
And so I was just like wow, and so I
legislated for chemical reform to try and
at least get our standards in this
country to be more like Europe.
And a lot sorry,
not legislated, I lobbied for
the legislation for
chemical reform, excuse me, and
I did it twice and
basically as you know during COVID,
our health has been politicized.
And, it's basically whatever
opinion someone wants to
decide is truth becomes the truth,
versus facts.
And so, I was like, wow, we this
shouldn't be about a political party.
This is just common sense and
human health,
anyway I'm frustrated with the system.
I was like,
well how can I create a solution for
people that really has the ethics and
values around it human health safety?
Also, thinking about the planet,
[LAUGH] and sustainability.
[LAUGH] And
then obviously I think the last and
the most important piece of the puzzle
is really showing up for people and
meeting their needs no matter
where they live in the country.
It shouldn't be like I afford
the most expensive things and
so I can shop at a whole foods or
whatever type of grocery store,
but everyone else is sort of left out.
And I was like, that just isn't fair.
And also I felt like there weren't a lot
of companies that stood for health and
wellness.
That also like spoke my language.
I don't know I just feel like
I love beauty in design and
I love beautiful things in the home.
And I just felt like there was a way to
kind of like show up in a beautiful way,
but still have the ethos and the values
and ethics that I had as a person.
So that's really where the business
came from, and the idea, and
that's how it started.
>> Well,
I love the intergenerational aspect of it,
of watching your mom go through something,
experiencing something yourself and
then trying to create a solution for
your children.
That's obviously a really
wonderful brand story.
But obviously not everyone was sold
in the beginning, so I'm curious.
How did your business pitch evolve as you
experienced some initial naysayers or
some knows?
>> Yeah, and I think you have to know
your audience, know their capacity.
And originally I was pitching this
idea to start this business with
people in entertainment.
Not knowing that the very business model
in entertainment is incoming calls and
licensing deals, right?
And it isn't starting from the ground
up and investing in a concept.
Now I think Hollywood has gotten
a little bit more savvy and
I would say the success of my
company has moved the business to
be a little bit more open,
two different ways of operating.
I also think that because
the shift in access to content and
the Internet and habits changing and
consuming has changed so
dramatically over the last,
I mean 20 years, but really ten years.
So the business Hollywood has had to also
try and figure out where they fit in that.
And I think they're still challenged
because they're holding on
to a lot of the old sort of systems,
but yeah, so I guess I was pitching
this idea to the wrong audience,
that's first and foremost.
And then I started pitching it around to
different people outside of my scope.
And I would say,
while as an entrepreneur, you're so
excited and
you see you're end goal, right?
And you're moving towards that end goal,
you have to make it palatable for
what can happen here, and now, and today.
So it's like well you want to sell
the dream of this is going to be a global
brand that stands for the health and
well being of people in the planet.
And we're going to make not only build
community and educate people on how they
can live a better life, but we're also
going to create the solution for them.
And it's going to to be
in various categories,
around home detergents,
around bath and body products,
around baby products, and
around skin and beauty products.
For me, I had to distill my idea down
to the thing that was trendy and
hot in the moment where
investors were excited
to invest into these new business models.
And I knew that I didn't want to take
this concept to a retailer because I
didn't want the retailer to then,
because when you take your concept and
your idea and you build inside
of a retailer's environment.
They essentially get
to take the reigns and
mold it into what fits
into their business model.
And you often will
compromise on your values,
especially when you
are right out the gate.
I also knew I wanted there to be a charity
component, and I thought that was just
really important and I also really wanted
there to be diversity and inclusion.
Just embedded in the values and
the practices of who we are.
So all of those things I would
say are just very new concepts,
in apply in,
especially back in ten years ago,
people hadn't really seen successful bus
businesses that have values, like that.
I mean there's like
there were very few and
far between that hit on
all of those things.
And so I had to figure out like know
your audience distill the concept
down to what is hot in the moment that
people are excited to invest behind.
And make it, get your elevator
pitch down because I have
like 100 page deck with
everything from home paints and
furnishings and detergents.
All the way through to beauty products and
then brands that sit in different
price points and a distribution.
>> Like a [INAUDIBLE] site.
>> I mean,
I had the whole kit and caboodle.
And so I had to really distill it down to,
at the time,
what was hot was a predictable
subscription business model.
And I partnered with essentially
the guy that had paved the way for
that business model to come to life.
He founded LegalZoom and
another business called ShoeDazzle.
And so I partnered with him and pitched
him the business and he turned me down.
And then he came back about 18 months
later and I pitched him again.
And at that point he had had a kid and
saw his wife change her beauty habits,
change what she allowed in the house.
Throughout all of their
detergents in their home,
the cleaning products and basically
was shopping from a very small and
curated set to provide a healthy
environment for their their little child.
And so he was like, okay, so
people do change when they had kids and
they start thinking
differently about gradients,
chemical exposures, the planet and
those types of values.
I would say now, and so
when I partnered with him,
then we basically went on pitched sandhill
like five or six companies and VCs.
And we got five term sheets by the end of
the day and I was eight and a half months
pregnant and I was told by my doctor,
I wasn't allowed to fly anymore.
And that was my second child.
I was pregnant because it took me actually
three years to get to that point and
yeah I think you have to be very humble
if you want to be an entrepreneur.
Or be part of a business,
know what you know what we know
what you don't know and
the surround yourself with people
that really support your strengths and
your weaknesses.
>> Yeah I love that point about
knowing your audience and how his life
circumstances changed how he acted as an
audience member to receiving your pitch/.
And just that little moment of his
wife experiencing exactly what you're
talking about was all they really needed
to see as a benefit for the company.
So at business school in all of our
classes, we're constantly reading
case studies to learn about pivotal
moments in a company's history.
So we talked a little bit about the pitch,
we can fast forward to honest
CO is now an amazing company.
What do you think would be the inflection
point that you would choose if the GSB
were to do a case study?
>> It's interesting,
I would say going from and
operating from a startup and
that's a high-growth startup with
that sort of high-growth business model.
And really transitioning
into a more steady
state growth business model [COUGH] and
building the foundational
principles to operate,
like a business that could be around for
100 years.
Because the people that you bring in and
that can get capital
to start a company are very
different people that usually I
would say 99% of the time is
usually a very different team.
That can operate and
build out foundational principles for
a company that can stick around for
100 plus years.
>> I love that, and
speaking of teams actually,
an instrumental part of your
team is your current CEO.
I'm curious, how did you find him?
How did he convince you that
he was the right person?
That he was really going to be able
to carry your vision forward as CEO.
>> Nick worked at Clorox and actually,
when we were starting the business
when we had such high growth and
being a digital first business,
and building community.
It was such a different approach and
the values, and the ethics,
around how the wellness again,
was also such a different in
the way that we went about it.
Was such a different approach to the way
a lot of the big CPG companies operate.
And so we've had all of the big
companies knock on our door and
you have to take those meetings.
And so he had spent time with us and
looked at us years before and
really sort of understood
our business model.
And then when we were at time to bring
in a new team to really build those
foundational principles
>> I think because he had
historic data and understood the mental
model of like what needed to be true.
And also he had done it with bird bees
when they brought bird bees into Clorox.
And, he really has a very
creative approach to business and
I think you can't have someone who's so
stuck into what they know.
But you need to have someone
who's really genuinely open and
curious to building out what
the business needs at that moment.
And he really felt like he
was grounded and in and
having conviction about that but
then also I would say.
The other big piece of it is he really
lived this life these values are very
meaningful to him.
And his family he's a father
of four two sets of twins and
his wife and him and the kids they
live very much these values and
these are the types of products
they have in their home.
And this is how they live their life so
just those the purpose and
the mission of the company
really resonated with him so.
>> Have that, well,
an amazing moment that you had last year
was when you took the company public.
So congratulations not.
>> Yeah, I'm curious.
Did the IPO feel like
a moment to pause and
appreciate all of your accomplishments?
Or was it a wake up call
that new challenges and
opportunities were ahead of you?
For me, it was both.
I would say that every time we hit
a different sort of transition or
milestone, at this point I feel like
I've been through [LAUGH] it all.
And you'll see guys when you start
your own businesses [LAUGH].
And yeah, it almost felt like
we're starting from zero again and
building the foundation of what it means
to be and operate like a public company.
And now like we're building
those building blocks and
those foundational principles again,
but in this new space.
>> I love that, so I would be remiss if
I didn't mention your previous role and
current still role in Hollywood and
where I learned at least at your
talent agency CAA branding your
personal brand is everything.
And I'm curious what learnings
carried over from that world.
>> To the business world
I'm now at UTA but
I yeah I would say that
your personal brand
As someone in Hollywood but
then even someone like you or
any of you guys sitting there, you can't.
You guys are living in a very kind of,
it's sort of like welcome to
the party of being exposed.
You guys are living
a very digital reality.
And people pan on Earth who you are and
your past and
your life, if anything,
is much more on display,
I would say, than any other generation and
will continue to be on display.
And so where you go in your life and
who you surround
yourself with and
how you align yourself along the way
will have an impact on
your future opportunities.
And so I think for me, I was always very
cognizant of that from a very early age.
And I think it's just something to
be mindful of depending on what
your aspirations are, making sure
that you own all of your decisions.
And you are honest with
yourself along the way and
I'm not saying don't be fearful but
just be aware and
I think a lot of people don't
always think of step three, four and five.
They just see the shiny penny in
front of them, and they get excited.
But I always think of three, four and
five because I didn't have a backup plan.
I didn't grow up with a safety net.
I had to create my own.
So I think I just operated with that
in mind when I was building out or
making any decision from age 12 on.
>> Right, yeah and important to note that
it started so young and social media and
everything has changed so much and
you've been adapting since you were 12,
which was is amazing.
I'd love to talk about the future
of where honest is going.
You recently launched the daily defense
collection,
>> [LAUGH]
>> Which is a line of skincare
products designed to defend against
environmental pollutants which is so
incredibly important.
I'm curious how do you-
>> [INAUDIBLE] screens,
who knew these screens could
affect your skin, my god.
>> [LAUGH] The screens that are currently
blasting stuff at us right now.
>> All day [LAUGH]
>> I'm curious how you predict
future trends and
continue to build products for the future.
>> A lot of it comes from I think
trusting my gut and my intuition.
It's weird like I don't
necessarily need McKinsey data,
to substantiate where I like,
what I feel or what I know.
And oftentimes, I feel like I can be
in not everything is a home run but
if you will need a bain or
McKinsey study to validate your
marketplace opportunity,
it's often a little too late.
Because the trendsetters
did it three years before,
it became a trend that it would even
become a case study or a study at all.
And so I would say that keeping
your feet on the ground and
really understanding the pain point or
the needs that you
are filling in whatever
business you're creating.
For me it's being very consumer
centric and very personal.
I always start from that place and
then I do my research from there
on around sort of like what other
companies are doing things like this or
what other like our
sensitive skin care line.
All of us want benefits in our
skin care we want brightening and
we want our fine lines to go away and
we want you know our
discoloration to go away.
We want to have those skincare benefits
in our skincare we just don't.
We're not looking for something that's
just sort of like, put this on your face
and it'll be a shield and then there you
go and it's better than having this rush.
Now, I'm allergic to
a lot of those products,
even the gentle ones that
the dermatologists recommend.
So I couldn't even use those.
So I was like, how about we have
a skin care routine that works for
people with really sensitive skin but
actually like does something for you.
And our head chemists she has
very sensitive skin as well.
And so that's just something where we were
like hey if you get rashes if you have
sensitive skin a lot of people who break
out a lot also have very sensitive skin.
There's nothing for you and
you're sort of just left in the dust.
So I was like this would be a cool one
to be able to create a full solution
where you can have exfoliation,
brightening, really hydrating.
We have a lightweight moisturizer and
a heavier moisturizer so it's for
different types of skin.
It doesn't clog your pores,
all of those things.
So that's another a lot of it
comes from the personal and
then you look at the marketplace and
you see how many people are doing it.
And then there's other things where you're
just like hey, this is table stakes.
You need to have X or
you need to have Y in order
to really like be in this category.
So, it's a blend.
>> Yeah,
I love how your ideation process for
new products kind of always goes back
to how you started honest itself,
which was based on problems
that you experienced yourself.
And obviously you're not
the only one to experience those.
>> Right.
>> So we started this talk with a TikTok.
[LAUGH] You are a parent to Gen Z kids and
a marketer.
And I'm curious because we
are always talking about Gen Z and
I feel like articles are always Gen Z this
Gen Z that as a parent and as a marketer.
What is something you think we're
getting wrong about that generation?
>> I think we try to overcomplicate it and
the gap of understanding feels so wide,
And I think there's sort
of like a frustration in
the way that they're moving at a pace and
are going to continue to move
at a pace that is beyond any
other generation just
because in the digital age.
Before you had to reimagine your
business sort of like every five years.
And then I would say about ten years ago
when I launched honest, it was like no,
you've gotta reimagine your business and
how you operate and
the way that you do it every three years.
Now, I would say it's like every
year you've gotta reassess and
reevaluate and reimagine.
I think that because they're so
young, maybe it's hard to,
Trust that they know what they're
talking about and allow them to.
Take some leadership and hand the baton
over like know what you don't know and
also like,
if something is meant to appeal to them it
doesn't necessarily need to
appeal to me or to you, right?
And sometimes it'll appeal to me and
it'll appeal to you.
But I think that is one thing that like,
I feel like when you're running
a business or when you're trying
to understand a demographic,
you feel like you should also
be on the same page as them but
it's totally okay that they
think the way that they think.
And they respond to things differently
than you and you don't need to take it
personally and know that it's okay for
you to have your differences.
What I appreciate about Gen Z and
I actually don't think of it
as being an issue is just
that they love authenticity.
They are values driven.
And the brand values
are meaningful to them and
the more that you really
show up authentically,
the better I think the businesses
that are in trouble and
appealing to Gen Z are the ones
that are trying to be tricky.
>> Well a clear of today for
sure is knowing your audience and
you clearly know this audience as well.
So much about honest Co is
educating the consumer.
You've been doing that since
before you even started.
The company as many of us here
are looking to start new businesses.
Some of them might be quite complicated
deep tech, web three, what have you.
What lessons can you share about what
works best in educating your consumer?
>> Make it entertaining if it's boring for
you to watch,
it's going to be boring for
anybody to watch.
What I mean, if it's boring to read it,
it's going to be boring for everyone.
I think more and more because we have so
much It's almost like
the volume of content, it is so
daunting and overwhelming and
is only going to get
more daunting as we start to
integrate AR into our day to day.
And as we integrate more
of the Web 3 into our
day to day with wearables and all that,
we're going to almost have
information overload and
so having really short and sweet,
pithy Ways of communicating,
no matter if you're a software company or
not even a B2B.
I would say when we're
choosing partners for
the B2B type of partners are something
that will help a function for
in our company and
in some form or fashion.
We're always looking at how
difficult is it to integrate and
usually the difficulty has
to do with how boring it is.
To [LAUGH] understand it and to apply it.
In making your materials as consumer
facing as possible is important even for
software companies or B2B is.
>> That's great advice.
Thank you.
So you've shared incredible
advice with all of us.
And we're all super grateful for
your time.
And you're also an incredible model for
so many founders from underrepresented
groups and for women, so
thank you for being here today.
I could go on forever, but we do have
some questions from the audience.
So I would like to to turn it over
to our first question from Jay Why.
>> Hi, Jessica.
I'm originally from Singapore and
moved to the Bay to attend a GSB.
I'm an aspiring entrepreneur,
so super excited to be here.
And my question for you is, what are some
of your biggest fears in building
the honest core and
how do you overcome them?
>> Maybe my biggest fear was not
connecting with my truth in a way and
allowing people who had trust and
a history in business sort of
take over the narrative or
run the business in a direction that
I intuitively knew wasn't right.
>> And
I felt imposter syndrome because I didn't
have a traditional business degree and
backgrounds.
And so it took me a hot minute to really
like step into my skin as a person and
I think the more I've trusted
my intuition and my gut and
stood in my truth,
the better I feel in everything, right?
In business and and in life.
But I would say that was my biggest fear.
It's scary when you've never
done it before, right?
Absolutely thanks for sharing.
>> Hi Jessica.
My name is Kristen Lim and
I am also an aspiring entrepreneur,
looking to do something
within the beauty space.
I'm also a power user of honest products
and I can't live without my magic mom.
[LAUGH] I'm so impressed with honest
growth in just the first year you've
achieved 12 million in revenue and
this grew to a staggering 150 million
in revenue just two years later.
And at the GSB we use the lean startup
methodology for profit Product ideation.
And I know from the talk that you
talked about honest product ideation
starting from your own pain points, but
I'm curious as honest continue to scale
how the product ideation process evolved.
>> Yeah, I mean, I would say that it
started from a very pure place and
then [LAUGH] I allowed I sort
of gave away my power and
my truth for a little while.
And I allowed for
it to be a bit of a mosh pit of everyone
wanting to chime in and
not having clear roles and
responsibilities and
boundaries defined, and,
I think I'm still a work in
progress when it comes to that,
but t76jhe biggest thing is really, again,
trusting your instincts,
knowing what needs to be true in order for
you to have a real authentic
positioning in the marketplace.
For me, I knew my gut was telling me
from day one we needed to have an in
house lab and an in-house team and a
regulatory team and also a sourcing team.
Because that was the only way we were
going to have true differentiation in our
formulas that can meet the standards
of conventional or exceed them.
And if I was just going to
operate like other companies
there was no way to get there.
It was just going to be
too many hurdles and so
I went through all the hurdles, right?
But that is the biggest thing is just know
what needs to be true for you in order for
you to have a real authentic position and
also a reason for you to even exist.
It's a crowded marketplace so
why are you here and
what are you doing that's
materially different.
>> Thank you so much.
[MUSIC]